From cowboy shootouts to shocking scenes
at a Native American residential school,
Taylor Sheridan's 1923 takes viewers
from rural Montana to Africa and beyond.
Here's a behind the scenes look at
the latest Yellowstone spin-off.
Though the flagship Yellowstone series has been
on the air for five seasons, each more intense
than the last, not every spin-off has received
a second round. 1883 was a one-and-done limited
series that creator Taylor Sheridan himself
described as a, quote, "10-hour movie with an
ending." Rather than simply continuing the
story, 1923 skips forward four decades to
witness the now-established Duttons fight for
survival during Montana's Great Depression.
But unlike its predecessor, 1923 earned a
second season with the promise to continue
the exhilarating story of Jacob and Cara
Dutton into another year. While this isn't
the first Paramount-Sheridan co-production
to find itself with more stories to tell,
it is the first Yellowstone spin-off
to earn a direct continuation.
When talking with Deadline about the renewal,
Sheridan revealed that the second season
would also consist of eight episodes.
Explaining why the 1883 follow-up would
be more than a single season, he said,
"I need to do this in two blocks. An eight-episode
block and a second eight-episode
block to wrap this up. [...] For
[Paramount], it is great because they get
more content. For me, I get more runway."
One thing's for sure, we can't
complain about more Dutton adventures.
When Sheridan first announced his new wave
of Yellowstone spin-offs, 1923 was originally
billed as a different series altogether. Wanting
to tell the story of Montana's Great Depression,
which began before the economic catastrophe
hit the rest of America in the 1930s,
Sheridan had initially titled the series 1932. But
a deeper dive into Montana's history changed that.
By the time the series entered production, the
last two digits in the title had swapped. Rather
than chronicling the nationwide Great Depression,
the series tackles the fallout of World War I,
the 1920s Prohibition era, and Montana's own
Depression, which started nearly a decade earlier
and involved a host of cattle and range wars.
While the premise of a Great Depression-era tale
is interesting in and of itself, 1923 is unique
in that it can cover multiple eras of American
and world history at once all while invoking
the works of John Steinbeck in the process.
No doubt, the change served the series well in
the long run, allowing for it to include Spencer
Dutton's post-War voyage to Africa as a hired
gun. This has been one of the more impressive
storylines on the series and has stretched the
Yellowstone franchise into international waters.
In addition, the commentary on
the impulsiveness of the 1920s
mixed with the desperation of a depression
makes for some instantly dramatic content.
"He survived the night. That's a start."
It's no secret that the years 1923 and
1883 are more than a couple decades
apart. Since most of the 1883 cast is
killed off by the limited series' end,
that leaves very few options for the Dutton family
to continue their bloodline. Because of this,
James Dutton's older brother Jacob and his wife
Cara take over the Dutton homestead and carry on
the family legacy in 1923. Though Harrison
Ford and Helen Mirren headline the series,
there are two others who bridge the gap
from the first prequel and this one.
For starters, the series is narrated by actress
Isabel May, who played Elsa Dutton — the firstborn
daughter of James and Margaret, on 1883. Though
Elsa dies in 1883, her spirit still haunts her
family's land, and intends to watch over the
Dutton legacy from afar. May herself is the
only cast member from 1883 to lend her talents
to Sheridan's latest prequel, vocal or otherwise.
Of course, a young John Dutton Sr. was
present during the events of 1883 as well,
played then by Audie Rick.
Though Rick doesn't return,
John Sr. is the only character from 1883 to
physically return in 1923, though not for long.
While most actors prefer to see a script
before signing onto a commitment like 1923,
neither Harrison Ford nor Helen Mirren did so.
Though he'd planned all of 1883 out beforehand,
Taylor Sheridan had only a rough
idea of where he wanted 1923 to go,
though he knew exactly who he wanted
to cast. He told Deadline in 2022,
"I need to know who I'm writing for.
I'm done wondering who I'm writing for,
and I have to go try to chase the
person I had in my mind and I can't
get the person because they're
doing some [other] Netflix show."
This wasn't so with Ford and Mirren. In
that same interview, Sheridan explained
that Ford flew himself down to Texas to
meet with him at his own private ranch,
and he talked the movie star
into it over a bottle of wine.
"I have what my family fought for."
Sheridan went on,
"Then came Helen [Mirren], and
same thing. Have a glass of wine."
Sheridan has quite a reputation in Hollywood,
one that flocks big names
towards the Yellowstone universe.
In an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter, Ford explained why he took
roles on both Shrinking on Apple TV+
and Sheridan's latest prequel, saying,
"I took the job without a script
on both of them, on faith that the
people who created the projects were
going to deliver me a good script."
Would you believe that 1923 is one of the most
expensive television projects ever? With Harrison
Ford and Helen Mirren on board, not to mention the
immaculate set design and production value that
tosses us backwards a century, there's no denying
that the latest Taylor Sheridan Yellowstone series
is putting its money where its mouth is. In fact,
Sheridan told Deadline that he believes 1883 was
the most expensive first season ever made, only
for 1923 to exceed that. Sheridan told Deadline,
"I don't know what the Game
of Thrones budgets were,
but I don't know how they could
have been more than this."
"You're going to hang us? Hey? Hang me!"
In the same interview, the
filmmaker estimates they're
spending around $22 million per episode, saying,
"I didn't do very good in math in school.
But I can multiply eight and three and
add a bunch of zeros and realize I
just asked for 150 million dollars."
No doubt, Game of Thrones averaged $15
million per episode by its final season,
meaning that the budget for
1923 quickly surpassed it.
When compared to the flagship series,
1923 cost more than the first three
seasons of the Kevin Costner-led production
combined. According to The Salt Lake Tribune,
Yellowstone spent somewhere around $80 million
in Utah during the series' first few years
back when they used to film there rather
than in Montana. With the show's success,
that budget has no doubt gotten larger, but
certainly not as large as $150 million total.
Though the Yellowstone saga is most well-known
for shooting primarily in Montana — a change
the franchise made after a few years of filming
in northern Utah — not every plotline in 1923
revolves around the Dutton family ranch. Though
the flagship series primarily shoots in Missoula,
Montana, 1923's time in Montana
was mostly centered in Butte.
A historic mining town, Butte lies about halfway
between Bozeman and Missoula and gives off a
turn-of-the-century vibe that lends itself well
to the 1920s time period. But not every 1923
character resides in Montana. As Spencer Dutton
spends the majority of the series away from the
family homestead, his adventures with Alex take
him across Africa and into international waters
in hopes of reaching the United States. But these
scenes weren't shot in some Hollywood studio.
"Darling there are not words to describe
the pickle we just found ourselves in."
"Is it bad?" "We need a higher tree."
Unlike the other Yellowstone series,
which exclusively film within the U.S.,
1923 branched out with on-location shooting
in Africa. The show's first season made
its way into a few different countries
across the globe, including South Africa,
Kenya, Tanzania, and Malta, which is
considered part of Southern Europe.
The production even stopped briefly
in Kabul, the capital of Afghanistan,
which is technically part of Asia. Including North
America, that's four continents touched by 1923.
Ever since Yellowstone became the
Paramount Network's breakout hit series,
the long-running Hollywood studio has given
Taylor Sheridan free reign when it comes to
the Yellowstone universe and beyond. Launching
four different series since the flagship series'
success, Sheridan has built quite the catalog of
Paramount-produced content that only seems to keep
growing. Between the Yellowstone spin-offs and his
other unrelated stories, Sheridan's got it made.
When the first episode of 1923 debuted on
Paramount+, it instantly broke every record
as the streamer's biggest series debut. After
1923 garnered upwards of 7 million viewers,
Paramount Media Networks' CEO Chris McCarthy
deemed it the #1 new cable premiere of the year,
making the second season a sure-fire thing. As
the story of the 1920s band of Duttons continues,
the intrigue and mystery surrounding Donald
Whitfield's land-grabbing plot grows,
and will no doubt continue to bring
more viewers in. David C. Glasser,
101 Studio's CEO, said of the screenwriting,
"[Sheridan's] scripts attract not only the best
actors working today but the best crew around.
[...] We are so fortunate these huge audiences
tune in to be a part of his universe every week."
Between the globe-trotting spectacle,
the gorgeous cinematography, and the powerful
performances by Harrison Ford, Helen Mirren,
and the rest of the phenomenal cast, it's
obvious why audiences continue to show up.
"Grab ahold of this. Catch your breath."
When 1923 first aired, there was a lot of initial
confusion as to who the characters are and where
they land on the Dutton family tree. To set the
record straight, Harrison Ford's Jacob Dutton
is the older brother of Tim McGraw's James, the
family patriarch from 1883. Though Jacob and his
wife Cara don't have children, they've come to
see James' sons John and Spencer as their own.
While John dies early on, his son Jack continues
on the Dutton name and legacy with his wife Liz.
Fans of 1883 and 1923 might've been a bit confused
by the addition of Spencer Dutton, who doesn't
appear at all on the former series since he hasn't
been born yet. But flashbacks to the year 1893 —
as seen during Yellowstone Season 4 — reveal that
Spencer was born sometime after the death of his
older sister Elsa. Though there's some debate
as to whether Spencer or Jack will father John
Dutton II, it's possible that Jack is actually a
younger John himself, though only time will tell.
There's no doubt that the works of Taylor
Sheridan are highly praised by audiences
across the country, but his content isn't exactly
for the faint of heart. His 2017 movie Wind River
features a horrific rape scene that highlights
the plight of many Native American women,
and many episodes of Yellowstone have shed light
on the same. Though nothing can prepare audiences
for the brutality of the Indian boarding school
scenes in 1923, which really push the envelope.
"Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay."
"Okay what?"
Prior to shooting, actor Sebastian
Roché, the man behind Father Renaud,
reportedly apologized to his Indigenous
castmates, not wishing to sugarcoat this
dark chapter in North American history. When
talking with TV Insider, Roché explained,
"In 1923, those residential schools were a
blight on our history. I think it's a very
important subject matter to talk about, because
it's something that we really don't know about."
Roché said he believes that,
as storytellers, their goal
shouldn't just be entertaining audiences,
but challenging them with the truth, adding,
"I felt a responsibility as an
actor to be as truthful as I could."
It's true that the residential schools
were horrific, and as recently as May 2022,
the United States alone has found 53
different burial sights associated
with them. Now is certainly the time to shed
some light on this horrific period in history.
Many of the cast members of 1923 were forced
to endure Taylor Sheridan's cowboy boot camp
to prepare them for the harsh conditions
of Montana ranch life. Sheridan has a
history of making his worlds feel authentic by
hiring real-life cowboys like Forrie J. Smith
as members of the Yellowstone cast. Brian
Geraghty, who plays Dutton ranch hand Zane,
revealed to E! News that Sheridan's boot
camp wasn't exactly a walk in the park.
"And so we were running on horses, lassoing,
learned how to use an old six shooter."
But one cast member wasn't forced to endure the
rigorous training prior to production. Harrison
Ford got out of it, but only because he's a ranch
owner himself. He told The Hollywood Reporter,
"I've owned horses for 40 years. I lived
in Wyoming for 40 years. I'm still living
there part-time. It's just getting
back in contact with horses, really."
According to The Land Report, Ford's owned
his Jackson-based ranch since the 1980s,
which is all the necessary qualifications
he needs to play a Dutton. If anyone
knows what it means to preserve
what's yours, it would be Ford,
who keeps both his treasured land and his
personal life pretty close to the chest.